[Music]
inner Mongolia is China's Montana
its Winters are cold its summer is hot
and it's wide open spaces isolated and
unforgiving
which makes it a very strange place to
build a giant 200 foot tall red
Victorian Palace
sure the Rich and Famous have been known
to make some unorthodox architectural
decisions
but way out here near the Gobi desert
you won't find any tennis courts golf
clubs or art museums never mind a Trader
Joe's
in fact the only amenities include a
highway Interchange to Nowhere a
non-functional airstrip and an Indiana
jones-style cardboard cutout City
this place was never meant to be lived
in
it was built as target practice on
China's largest military base
and the people's Liberation Army clearly
had a very specific mission in mind
this is that 200 foot tall Palace in the
desert
and this is taiwan's presidential office
building in Downtown Taipei
lest you mistake the replica for a mere
Roadside Attraction State media released
footage of Chinese troops using it to
simulate an invasion
needless to say this is deeply
unsettling
that the Chinese military is actively
practicing an invasion of its small
Democratic neighbor should attract the
world's attention and outrage
and it's not evidence of an imminent
plan to attack
we know that because it was built nine
years ago
yet the failure of our worst fears to
materialize hasn't prevented the same
dire warnings from being recycled year
after year since
just a few months ago for example U.S
Air Force General Mike minahan wrote a
memo to his 50 000 subordinates that
began with I hope I am wrong my gut
tells me we will fight in 2025.
another mic from the U.S military
Admiral Mike gildy made headlines last
year for saying he couldn't rule out a
Chinese attack in 2022 or 3.
each time the evidence simply
accumulates
every authoritative prediction or
alarmist headline reinforces the
perception that war is inevitable or
even imminent
where there's smoke there must be fire
but Taiwan has now been on the brink of
War for most of a decade which means
we're long overdue for some reflection
sponsored by China actually my six-part
series available only on nebula
let's start with what we know
first few countries have transformed so
completely as China since 1949.
yet despite these 74 years of continuous
tumultuous change during which not even
the written language survived untouched
on one issue China has been remarkably
consistent
every leader since Mao has reaffirmed
the importance of unification
despite having never governed Taiwan the
party defines itself as the rightful
heir to and guardian of Chinese history
culture and more problematically the Han
ethnicity
America's involvement in the region and
taiwan's growing national identity
certainly add insult to injury but the
mere existence of another government
that claims the label Chinese is already
perceived as a threat
second we know that in the last two
decades China has rapidly modernized its
military
truthfully neither the size of its Fleet
nor its budget are perfect measures of
anything Chinese ships are generally
smaller and its budgets easily distorted
besides how does one accurately discount
the abilities of an army that hasn't
fought a single major war for nearly
half a century
but although experts disagree about the
relative strength of the Chinese and
American militaries there's no doubt the
gap between them is shrinking
what was once a guaranteed U.S victory
is now uncertain
finally we also of course know that
despite its explicit intent and growing
capability China hasn't yet invaded
the question and where facts become
speculation is why not
one interpretation is that China is
waiting to cross some threshold of
tactical superiority
once it does which could be any day now
war is inevitable
the advantage of this theory is its
simplicity
when Xi Jinping says Taiwan quote must
and will be reunited with China it
doesn't take a wild imagination to hear
we can and will invade
when he repeatedly mentions the year
2049 as the target for China's
Rejuvenation it's not outlandish to
interpret this as a hard deadline for
unification
after all it isn't as if this increasing
assertiveness is confined to words
here's a timeline of recent Chinese Gray
Zone tactics aimed at Taiwan coercive
activities that fall somewhere between
normal diplomacy and outright War
instance in 2016 it suspended all
communication
in 2019 its fighter jets flew closer to
the island than they had in the previous
two decades
and the next year Beijing stopped
importing Taiwanese pineapples one of
its largest Industries
clearly proponents of this Theory aren't
hallucinating tensions are undeniably
growing
but although intuitive this theory is
not without its weaknesses
namely if war is inevitable why give
your opponent a specific timeline
generally speaking politicians prefer to
keep their options open why needlessly
impose on yourself a deadline
at a time when the U.S and Taiwan are
looking for reasons to increase their
defense budgets why give them the
literal and rhetorical ammunition they
need
China's best Hope For Success would
involve quick decisive action giving
America little time to respond
yet not only does China not hide its
intentions it releases footage of its
replica presidential building online
if that first Theory sees the current
moment as a critical turning point where
China is on the verge of finally
following through on its promises a
second one sees as much continuity as it
does change
sure China has recently become more
aggressive
but this timeline only goes back to 2016
during which Taiwan has only had one
president and one ruling party
now watch what happens when we extend
the timeline to the year 2000.
from then until 2008 Taiwan was led by
the green Democratic Progressive Party
which is skeptical of Engagement with
China
the DPP at the time inched closer to
declaring independence than it ever has
close enough that after China protested
George Bush stepped in to warn the
island not to proceed
following this incident Beijing enacted
the anti-secession law in 2005 which
made explicit its long-standing threat
to invade if Taiwan declared
independence
all this changed in 2008 when the DPP
lost to the blue kuomintang or kmt which
promotes engagement with China and is
strongly opposed to Independence
for the next eight years its relations
with China were the warmest they've ever
been the two presidents met shook hands
and signed a free trade agreement
today it may feel like a lifetime away
but less than a decade ago many laughed
at the idea that China would invade an
economy it was investing billions of
dollars in
then in 2016 the DPP returned to power
while it no longer Advocates
Independence it has strengthened its
unofficial relationship with the United
States
in response China cut off all
communication banned many Taiwanese
Imports and conducted increasingly
elaborate military exercises
now it's impossible to prove whether
China would have become more hostile
even if the kmt had remained in power
but this timeline certainly suggests a
clear relationship between the Taiwanese
government and China's approach
this is not at all to blame Taiwan
Beijing chooses its reactions
it does however suggest a logic to this
reprehensible aggression
think of China's position as a spectrum
on one side is its ideal outcome
unification
on the other side are its red lines most
believe that China would invade today if
Taiwan declared independence
in between is a range of more and less
tolerable scenarios
with the kmt in charge Independence is
off the table China relaxes and uses
carrots to gently pull Taiwan toward
unification
when the DPP is elected China switches
to a coercive stick approach to push
Taiwan away from its red lines
when viewed this way shi's speeches
sound a lot more like threats than
announcements
when he seems to contradict himself by
saying quote we will continue to strive
for peaceful reunification but we will
never promise to renounce the use of
force you could stress the force parts
and dismiss the word peaceful as nakedly
disingenuous
after all China has been disingenuous
about Hong Kong xinjiang and the South
China Sea
you could also do the opposite and
ignore what's obviously a threat
but there's a third possibility
these two promises aren't contradictory
China genuinely means both
on one hand the idea of promising not to
use force is seen as a dangerous
concession because it's the only thing
preventing Taiwan from declaring
independence it would forever close the
door to unification
at the same time waging an actual War
would be extraordinarily costly
Taiwan produces roughly 92 percent of
the world's most advanced semiconductors
nearly a fifth of the Chinese population
lives in the three provinces closest to
Taiwan
and 90 of the world's largest ships
Transit through the Taiwan Straits
even if they could take the longer route
through Indonesia it would increase
shipping costs by an estimated half a
billion dollars each month
collectively a one-year War would reduce
America's GDP by five to ten percent and
China's by 25 to 35 percent according to
one study from 2016.
now let's be clear these are wild
guesses no one can realistically predict
the outcome of a war between two nuclear
Powers with any accuracy
the only thing we can say with certainty
is that such a conflict would fall
somewhere between absolutely
catastrophic and existential
XI jinping's 2049 milestone for China's
national Rejuvenation includes economic
Prosperity something incompatible with
any invasion of Taiwan whether
successful or not
so yes China does prefer peaceful
unification of course it would rather
achieve all of its goals without
suffering any of the costs
similarly projecting a willingness to
fight offers many of the benefits of
actually fighting but few of the costs
toughness plays well to a domestic
audience
it appeases a powerful political faction
the military it helps build xi's
Personal Image it's an insurance policy
against embarrassment in case of a
confrontation
and it deters Independence
2049 could be a genuine deadline it
could also be as the 100th anniversary
of the PRC a symbolic placeholder that
feels far away yet signals conviction
yet is also vague and non-binding the
perfect political promise
some observers claim she has urged the
pla to quote dare to fight
but other Chinese speakers argue the
phrase could just as easily mean dare to
struggle
at the very least his choice of words is
deliberately ambiguous
by definition deterrence only works when
indistinguishable from actual
mobilization
in other words it's impossible to prove
whether China is simply deterring
Independence or genuinely preparing for
an attack
having a larger stronger military is
useful whether or not it fights
when taken as a whole all the evidence
proves definitively is that we simply
don't know when or if China will invade
the trouble with this indeterminate
conflicting evidence is that it's ripe
for cherry picking
sometimes this ambiguity is cynically
exploited
the more urgent the threat facing
America the more resources are directed
to the military
but there are legitimate or at least
understandable reasons too
the military's fundamental and in fact
singular mission is to prepare for every
contingency no matter how unlikely
the real Scandal would be if Admiral
Mike gildy did rule out a Chinese attack
in 2023 or if General Mike minahan
wasn't anticipating the worst possible
outcome
Anyone who reads General minahan's memo
in full will see that it clearly wasn't
written for a civilian audience it uses
Air Force jargon and adopts the tone of
a Stern confident Superior
no one has to be doing their job poorly
for the threat to be exaggerated
the issue may be that someone is doing
their job
the problem arises when this mindset
escapes the walls of the Pentagon
in the media not only do These Warnings
lose their institutional context the
organizational paranoia that we the
public demand from the Armed Forces but
they carry undue credibility
at the end of the day these are just
guesses that fact is confirmed by the
sheer diversity of predictions
despite this they carry significant
Authority
as one political correspondent wrote I
don't know if or when China will invade
Taiwan but I figure that when someone
like four-star Air Force General Mike
minahan writes we should probably sit up
and take notice
the United States should prepare for an
invasion
the consequences of a potential conflict
would be so devastating that we simply
can't afford not to take the threat
seriously after all Putin's war in
Ukraine demonstrates that no one's sober
rational judgment can be taken for
granted
the challenge is to prepare for war as
if it were inevitable without succumbing
to a self-fulfilling prophecy
to train for a Sprint while not losing
sight of the fact that we may be running
a marathon
if conflict is a chronic not acute
challenge for example America would be
better off investing in not diversifying
away from the Taiwanese economy which
only makes it more dependent on China
U.S China tensions are unlikely to
dramatically improve in any lasting way
in the foreseeable future which makes
careful management of that relationship
more important than ever
but it's precisely because an invasion
of Taiwan may not be guaranteed that we
should take it seriously our actions May
influence the outcome
if an invasion isn't guaranteed
exaggerating the threat could do more
harm than good
as experts Ryan Hass Bonnie Glaser and
Richard Bush point out while an actual
war is hypothetical China is already
engaged in a psychological war of
attrition
contrary to what many Americans assume
no individual Chinese missile fighter
jet or speech provokes much fear in
Taiwan
but cumulatively China's objective is to
slowly wear down taiwan's will to resist
to propagate a general sense of
uncertainty and insecurity
in a 2017 survey just 41 of the
Taiwanese public believed China would
attack if Taiwan declared independence
three years later that number Rose to 61
percent
if America's pessimism is more fatalist
than motivational it risks doing China's
work for it
and finally if or when we do detect
signs of an imminent Attack One of
America's first actions will be to
notify its allies
crying wolf today would undermine its
credibility tomorrow
in the early 2000s for example a Chinese
General made headlines for claiming
hundreds of U.S cities would be targeted
with nuclear weapons if America defended
Taiwan in a war
this comment and others like it led to
panicked speculation about the true size
of China's nuclear stockpile
but this theory is likely wrong and this
kind of exaggeration does no good for
Taiwan
I explain why in this episode of China
actually which is available only on
nebula
in that same series we also explore four
other questions about China like why
most of the rare earth metals necessary
to build Electronics come from one rural
town in inner Mongolia and why Chinese
censorship is both more and less strict
than we often imagine
nebula the streaming platform built by
and for independent creators is the only
place you can watch these videos
there are no ads or sponsors and many
videos are available early
this one you're watching now for
instance has been available on nebula
since early July
nebula is home to dozens of other great
Originals too like Wendover Productions
the logistics of X and real life lore's
modern conflicts explaining the wars we
often hear about in the news but rarely
have time to truly understand
normally nebula costs five dollars a
month but you can get it for 50 off for
just two dollars and fifty cents a month
by signing up for a year with the link
on screen or in the description now
foreign